大家看盤的時候
眼睛是不是都只會盯著K線去看
然後覺得 欸 紅K好興奮啊
DK完蛋 死定了
但我跟大家說價格是可以做出來
特別在台灣市場裡面
所以主力只要透過一些砸錢的動作
可以讓K線變得很漂亮
然後再最後一盤偷拉等等的
那什麼東西是很難造假的
假如K線是可以造假的話
我會跟大家講
成交量很難造假
真金白銀很難造假
所以今天我們要講的東西是什麼
OEB
它不是單純去看K線價格的東西
它反而是看說
他有沒有把量給留下來
那這個錢是不是真的有留下來
那最近大盤你也知道
上上下下的起伏很大
然後個股長的一些就是奇奇怪怪的
那你也看不懂誰在騙人
如果你真的有這些困擾的話
一定要去學會這個指標
周周聽一點 財經變簡單
大家好 我是今天主持人肌肉書筒
今天有三件事要跟大家討論
第一個 OBV是什麼
第二個 如何判讀 OBV
第三個 散戶如何透過 OBV來賺錢
我們一鍵一鍵來慢慢拆解
第一階段我們就來討論
OBV是什麼
什麼是OBV
為什麼它很重要
我們先理解
OBV是計算一個量價指標
就是有量也有價
這是一個非常核心的原理
但是價格可以做
但是量一定要花錢
所以我們前面提到
真金白銀很重要
有人會把它叫做量能潮
有人叫它平衡交易量指標
我會說都對
我喜歡叫它量能潮
它的核心技術是看成交量的累積方向
它是一個加減分的概念
什麼意思
如果我們判斷一個股票啊
他要漲要什麼
要錢
那錢是什麼
成交量
如果成交量持續進場
他的OVE曲線會往上提高
那就代表說有實際買盤在買
雖然價格波動沒有很大
但至少確定有人在買
這件事很重要
那反之呢
OVE是往下掉
那價格也是往下掉
代表什麼
是不是有大人在出場了
所以這是一個加減分的概念
他的假設是什麼
我覺得這件事也很重要
他假設是量先於價
量先於價
這就是所謂的量價關係的核心基礎
所以如果你是學量價關係派的話
這個指標通常一定會用
無論你在做什麼程式交易
其實都會看這一個
我這邊給大家另一個邏輯好了
就是說 OBB 怎麼算的
其實他的計算是一個時間段
什麼叫時間段
當天的收盤價格大於前一天
然後 OBB 會等於是說
前一天的 OBB 加當下的交易量
那另一個
如果當天的收盤價格小於前一天
他的OBB就可能就呈現往下
所以OBB他的算法變成說
前一天的OBB去減掉當天的成交量
如果持平OBB就不會變
那你聽到這話是太複雜了吧我濃縮加減法給大家聽齁首先第一個如果今天的收盤價格比昨天來的高那今天成交量全部都是加分的
你說為什麼
代表有大戶進場而且他願意買
所以這對OBB來說是加分
所以就往上
那如果就是說今天的收盤價格比昨天收盤價格來的低
今天成交量全部都是扣分
他就會呈現在那個線路上面
這條線是拿來追蹤說資金他有沒有在裡面的主要看法
第二段要怎麼去判讀OBV
OBV他呈現的方式很可愛
就我只能說很可愛
因為他並不是說像NACD一樣
他有那種什麼快慢線沒有
OBV通常是一條線
他可能他有一個中軸
但是他中軸不一定是0
所以他的OBV指數會很誇張
有時候用什麼7、8千甚至有破萬的
他都很正常
所以你們不用去Care那個數字
他那個數字一點來說都不重要
你只要在意一件事就好
是否往你想要的方向去做
例如來說
它的方向跟形狀我們去做搭配
什麼叫方向
我是做多我希望 OBV 是一直往上走
那股價也是希望一直往上走
這個叫銅像
是好的
那如果我今天做空 OBV 往下加個往下
這也叫銅像
這也是好的
那形狀是什麼
形狀就代表說
我們股價一定會有所謂的成交量
那成交量堆積在那
可能有部分是均線
可能有部分是
今天的分價量表
你可以去拉出來
你看OVV是不是要穿過分價量表的最大壓力區的時候
那個就叫做形狀
所以通常這時候OVV他的曲視線會慢慢的這樣抖動上去
這件事你們可以同步去做一個觀測
那第二個
OVV有什麼黃金訊號
或者是有什麼幼多要去處理
我個人覺得OVV的黃金訊號
第一個就剛剛上一點有提到
可能要突破某一個關鍵壓力位置
你們可以去查那個叫分價量表
或是說你利用均線去看
這也是一個還不錯的訊號
我覺得 OBVE準備穿過可能長期均線
或是你是做短線一點的人
你可能我10日均線
甚至5日均線回檔以後有沒有機會再往上突破
這都是一種搭配用法
至於說有沒有什麼又多現金
有 這個要特別去注意
你們不要去買那種成交量很少的股票
因為那種成交量很少的股票突然鎖一根漲停
他的 OBVE 會呈現火箭發射狀態
就是平平的然後突然一根這樣
就覺得哇這 OBVE 太強了
實際上不是他很強
是因為它的統計方式本來就會被這影響到
那既然是說
它無法取出一個常態分布的話
是異常的
它就不要去做
因為那個十之八九不是什麼正常現象喔
那第三段我們來討論說散戶如何利用OBV來賺錢第一個我們先理解OBV他有什麼策略可以做他要搭配什麼指標第一個先理解OBV上行
就價格啦
我們先看價格
如果價格穩穩的在那邊
OBV開始有往上去推進
就是他價格是有點上下起伏
沒有很大
穩穩的這樣穩穩的可能在5%內
但OBV不斷往上推進
這可能就是一個還不錯的買點
就代表說有大戶先進場
只是還沒有那麼過分的買
這個就是我會去特別關注
那反之也是啊
最容易出現的現象是說
很多人喜歡去做突破熱門股
完全沒錯 這個交易策略是對的
但除了看價格跟看量
我們可以把 OBV 搭入進去
例如說你看他價格可能創新高了
但 OBV 卻一直往下掉
甚至低於他價格高點的時候 OBV
就代表說其實有人已經在慢慢離倉了
這時候是不是要先緩一緩
不要那麼快追進去
這才是一個比較好的買點策略
甚至是說如果真的滑架滑很兇
OBV不斷破底都還沒往上翻
這種東西反而更不應該去做抄底
因為很危險
代表說真的有人賣的很兇
那同樣的
OBV跟其他的技術指標差別會在哪
很多人是看價格漲多了沒
或是他反應是不是過於熱烈
但其實OBV是看他錢還在不在那邊
所以我們要搭配類似的策略
因為我來說分價量表就是一個還不錯的東西
甚至你要搭配NASCD好了
NASCD他會比較特別
有人NACD會去算什麼金交叉死亡交叉
但我個人覺得看那個沒什麼屁用
就講實話真的沒什麼用
我會弄NACD搭配OVV是建議給你們
你要關注一件事
NACD的基礎概念
你只要看NACD的零軸
零軸NACD是有一個區間嘛
他中間那條橫線叫零軸
零軸在那邊
NACD所有快慢線處於零軸以上
OVV開始往上揚
你搭配這個去做
通常這種股票短線趨勢都會很強
你說那我什麼時候要停利
很多人會想去停利
卻不知道怎麼停
當 OBB 往下降的時候就該停利
甚至你說
如果我想做一個可能比較長線的交易
我利用 OBB 加 NACD 的中軸概念可不可以去做
其實是可以的
就當 OBB 沒有跌破零軸的時候
你根本不用去做停順
有些人是這樣做啊
但我個人覺得
比較容易有一些誤差值在
所以看每個人習慣的交易會是哪一種
今天我們就來講一個例子
這算是我們剛剛有提到說OVV很容易被誤導的地方
首先第一個這是一個奇怪的股票
我們先不講是哪一檔
但你們有沒有看到它的成交量很奇妙成交量這時候都才幾張就很少啊,成交量都很少啊就少少的那,結果某一天突然開始爆量往上的時候就代表說他OVE會呈現這種垂直發射
但不代表說他很強,是因為代表他的可能之前成交量太少了
所以容易被大家給誤導
那至於會發生這種事的股票,你就盡量不要去碰
這是一個比較反面的例子
那有沒有比較正面的例子?也是會有的
那第二個我們就來看比較正常人會遇到的現象
例如說這個股票好了
他不是創新高,OBB也是高點嗎?
那其實這樣突破形態是好看的
是很好看的喔
但是你會發現,他股價開始下來的時候
OBB滑價的速度很快
那現在他出現的東西是什麼?
我們要把過去的事情跌入到現在
他曾經高點在這
所以你記住他OBB的高點喔
我們把他移動過來
發現OBB還沒創高,但價格很接近
那你要不要進場?
其實這時候不要等
就不要等
你要等的是OBB往上提高
價格跟著提高
這是一個進場點
或甚至是說 當OBV往上突破 價格還在這邊的時候
那可能也是一個買點 所以很多人會做錯的交易是在這邊
剛剛有提到就是說 有沒有比較正面的例子 就是趨勢性股票
像這個股票就是趨勢性很強 我們先不管4月 4月那一段根本就是炸虎
但是我們看到後面7月 你先記得這個高點
他OBV位置是在這 但OBV位置是在這裡
但是你們有沒有看到後面股價下來 OBV卻沒呈現很大的跌幅
甚至他股價在這裡的時候
他OVE在這裡的時候創新高了
已經接近創新高了
但是他的價格還沒創新高
代表實際買盤進場沿路往上推進
那後面也是啊
價格雖然一直往下掉
但是他OVE一直處於高位
延續往上推連續往上推連續往上推
所以代表說資金其實一直都在場內
直到最近啊
價格開始連續發動的時候
就呈現一個非常大的突破
那這個高低點算喔
了不起一個月從400塊漲到
最高點接近600塊
所以這個價差是很大的
所以我們就看 OBV 的時候
不是看他的曲線 也不是看什麼FV
也不是看他的絕對數值
反而你要參考他的方向性 跟自己跟過去的對比
如果發現 欸 價格往下掉
但 OBV 都還在場內的時候
也許就是一個還不錯的進場點
需要的是耐心與時間 而不是說
誰賺得快 誰賺得慢
就是抱得住 透過這種指標
其實是滿有交易機會的
這一般散戶都能去用
這就是 One Size Fixed All的交易技術
OVV是好东西,量能潮
听完今天的内容想来问一下大家
你会拿OVV来做交易吗?
A 会,拿来做交易这个胜率很不错
B 不会,看这个没有用
C 觉得有其他更好的指标
在影片下方留言告诉我你的想法
最后也提醒大家
记得按赞、分享、订阅、开启小铃铛
我们下次再见,拜拜!